are they gonna hold hands like best
friends any best friends you're holding
hands I can't wait to be a dad
this is one that's just gonna be my
opener so as you can see we are wearing
June B shirt he's wearing it too and we
are headed to June B in Westwood right
now because we have a meeting great and
hopefully some of you guys watching this
video we will be meeting in just a
minute this is gonna be the first time
that we get to see the remodeling and
like the new look of this location they
didn't like in a weekend or something
they completely revamped the entire
store seven days oh I took a week I
think so oh we took a page from the
Bible
we have us a really quick turnaround for
this remodeling slow facelift for the
rebrand and I'm really excited to see it
because I got to see the concept are
like the mood board and some concept
photos I guess of the store before they
did
in real life so I was able to see some
like 3d renderings of it and it looks so
good and I've already seen some like
stories and stuff from the June we
social media pages so I got to see it
but it's a whole nother thing to see it
in person so I'm really really excited
to see the new look of the store and to
meet you guys so I hope people showed up
because I only promoted this on my
stories and like within this past week
but Instagram is being mean and they're
not they're not showing like the
algorithm is like working against a lot
of us peoples that have creator or
business profiles so I did an experiment
this week
difficult you're stressing out this West
would turn is difficult you mean it okay
but yeah so I did an experiment where I
switched my profile over to a personal
profile to see if I can reach more of
the people who are following me and yeah
the numbers didn't come back like how it
usually hits so I don't know if anyone's
gonna show up today but I hope someone
shows up because it's gonna be kind of
it's gonna be kind of sad if it's like
hey we're here to meet you guys and then
no one even found out about it well it'd
be kind of cool for if it wasn't like a
huge turnout for the people that do show
up a lot more intimate time with you
exactly I mean that's one thing I hope
someone shows up having just having my
anyone I don't care if it's a big crowd
I really don't I just hope there's
someone here that is ready to like fight
it to meet us I'm excited to be them
I really hope someone shows up but yeah
I'm blaming Instagram because they're
not they're not the algorithm is working
against me so it's okay it's a constant
battle with these damn algorithms even
on YouTube you know a lot of you guys
have commented recently like oh I didn't
even know that you guys were uploading
still because you guys don't pop up in
my my sub box anymore or I don't get
notifications even though I click the
belt
so yeah the algorithms working against
against a lot of us out here in these
youtube social media streets
like the it's like the internet rain God
you know you have to do a dance tribal
dance around the five they're constantly
posed yeah I just want to reach the
people who wanna see us that's it it's
just like you know you guys followed for
a reason you guys subscribe for a reason
and it kind of sucks that you don't get
to see the stuff that we're putting out
so yeah I mean cuz we we create this yes
for us and like for ourselves and stuff
but also for you guys we're servicing
you guys but anyway we're getting close
we'll see you there
hi guys I'm so happy you came I was just
telling the camera that I'm like I hope
people show up yay let me go inside
really quick gonna help me too
[Music]
[Music]
okay Sansa go park the car
but we made it
[Music]
he made it sound parking and even made
it he's been waiting for you I got no
money I pulled it in to get to park
right and then I drop you off and then I
realized I was in line for in and out no
way to back up around like maybe you
should go into the other one
barking sounds like house that's so
funny I got the yuzu
[Music]
maybe later
I don't even have seaweed in my mouth
[Music]
[Music]
that is bad sauce today yeah
[Music]
three years in the past three years
right off the top my head
Jojo Abbi yeah psycho IDT you
[Music]
one of those threes where you take a
photo and they're talking about drinking
a yuzu matcha he has the dirty how long
have you been following kc-10 that's
cool obviously I didn't know that there
was gonna be a hangout today you just
happen to be out running a tea and Blair
hurt there her you know just a that's
awesome
wow you came at a good day
[Music]
like when they're and they're all like
the war companies whether you want to
see with two
like crazy I just remember like attends
like college tuition
[Music]
you see you're busy like
[Music]
ready
wait on let me try to like do this at
the same time
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright we just finished the meeting
greet and how was it it was so freaking
cool this was literally my most favorite
meet-and-greet I've ever done because it
was like really intimate and the people
that were there were freaking sweetest
ever they they oh my gosh like I felt
like crying so many times based off of
like how much gratitude everyone was
sharing with us and I'm like are you
kidding me
I love you are you serious you came all
the way out here just to say hi to us I
feel freaking special and and then like
I don't know connecting with them
so intimately was awesome because all
the other meet and greets I've ever done
it's been so rushed like you know
there's a big crowd of people and
there's always because it's always like
with the whole JK fan so there's a lot
of commotion going on and we can't ever
really connect one-on-one and then a lot
of the times you know it's just like
quick photo and then by quick photo and
my and it's just really hard to connect
with people that way but this time it
was so intimate I got to have a long
conversation with every single person
that was there today
I loved it man it was I felt so much
love and so much gratitude like both
ways you know like I felt the love for
the people I was meeting and then the
people that I was meeting I received
their love it was just amazing
ditto everything you just said I loved
how intimate it was past meeting greets
they it always feels rushed when there's
a lot of us that are you know trying to
you know like then there's a lot of JK
members there this time there was you
know a smaller group of us and yet we
finally had the time to like actually
connect and be more human about the meet
and greet because a lot of times meeting
creatures just a photo and Dunton photo
and done photo and done and and I just
feels really impersonal and yeah I don't
know really fun with them and I'm saying
how they appreciate like you know the
videos that we put out and everything we
share and put out there in the world
that they connect with and I'm just like
it just made me feel so great so I just
have a huge smile on my face I can't
wipe away
beautiful I loved it all right so now we
are off we're on the west side of town
we don't live out here and since we're
out here we thought we might make the
rounds and visit some friends and we are
going we are on our way to visit our
good friends aka Indiana and their new
baby boy boy he's not that new now true
true he's uh he's I think it almost -
isn't he very true yeah so you're gonna
go see them and yeah we haven't seen
them in a minute it's been so long
yeah because they live on the other side
of town just LA is huge
it's sprawling so big so just to get
from one side of LA to the other side of
LA it's like especially with traffic
it's a good like hour-and-a-half
[Music]
let's go a K was like my like best bud
in film school and we both moved out
here together to LA so we started our
careers together and
you know in since then we've kind of you
know grown in our own respective ways in
our industry and yeah it's always great
to catch up though so alright we just
arrived at a place get some lunch real
quick before meeting up with their
friends and TIFF doesn't want to walk in
this restaurant looking like we work at
thank you were like employees looking
uniform I mean these aren't technically
uniform so these are Jun be uniforms
right nothing I don't want to wear
they're not proud of Jeremy well that's
not the fact is that I'm like I did
bring extra clothes in case we were able
to change out of them but yeah like I
don't want to be one of those couples
that match and we're the exact same
things out so I'm like I'm gonna change
and then I started like I started
changing and then I was like oh you know
what this is kind of a cool thing to
vlog yeah so what what do we do it this
only works for if you're wearing if
you're trying to switch out of a big
shirt into like a smaller shirt so what
you do is you take your arms out or you
put it inside and they go inside the
shirt and then you put the shirt on this
way yeah see and then take this one off
again
tada magic tricks magical because we
can't just we can't just take off our
shirts and expose ourselves like guys
can so we this trick are you a are you
an advocate of free the nipple yeah the
awesome of girls didn't have to worry
about it but I'm not gonna be an early
adopter of it to it once everyone's
desensitized to it but then you've not
in our lifetime I think you could also
have the argument of like well if you're
not gonna be part of it and our is it
gonna be popularized
[Music]
they know their program to talk to each
other all right show me array Oh what
he's a bully what he's got a hard ad
yeah but but let your flight know okay
you can't fly okay you can't fly
are they gonna hold hands like best
friends are the best friends you're
holding hands I can't wait to be a dad
this is fun
[Music]
I can't wait to be a dad
this is one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've been there you're getting ready I
am ready for this
that looks fun round to you
[Music]
[Music]
what are you guys doing you want you
must do this I mean he literally running
on full right now cuz you just got out
of a nap so cute Oh where's knee time
maybe you gotta get lower
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]